momentum stocks have kind of
underperformed the last week small caps
internet names biotechs is that perhaps
a sign that we should be cautious even
as we've seen this incredible v-shaped
recovery I think there's been a
tremendous amount of choppiness so far
in the market in 2014 and you know we've
seen that tech stocks take off and then
collapse so we've seen hedge funds take
on very concentrated positions in a
couple of these sectors and then back
away and a couple pull backs and greater
than five percent which by the way is
normal for for a year and people have
forgotten that because we've gotten to a
period where we had very few pullbacks
we'd very few moments of volatility in
the markets and everyone had gotten
comfortable with just a straight ascent
and so now we think you know we're going
to see additional choppiness we'll see
some of these momentum stocks back off
we'll see some of the higher fliers
particularly on the evaluation side gets
sold off when people get fearful but our
view is up still for the equity market
it's still up for now but are we moving
to a new phase I mean we've been
anticipating for so long where monetary
policy is no longer the biggest driver
of equities that's right you know this
it well it's no longer going to be the
biggest driver of just us equities what
we are seeing is a very divergent set of
monetary policies around the world and
that's going to govern how we think
about investing in allocating and assets
while the Fed is gonna be normalizing
policy we expect the ECB to adds more
stimulus the BOJ certainly gave us
another shot of adrenalin the last
friday with their announcement of
increased asset purchases and against
that backdrop I think you have to be a
lot more creative about how you're
allocating your assets and have a lower
expected return assumption for
especially for it but new mediocre that
you're referring to Christine Lagarde
Martin Sorrell doesn't agree with she
doesn't agree with me you're not a new
mediocre 'used no I'm in the in the
sense of what the world dribbling along
at lower growth rates yeah pulling along
that lower that's my code of the day
dribbling along is what we can do out of
it it's it's when we talk about a
v-shaped it's callousness have done
v-shaped recovery and much what happened
in 09 we have the the slump after Lehman
then we recovered sharply in 10 and then
it's almost like a square root sign with
us gently up up up line 11 was a record
for us 12
was a record for us 13 was a break over
us 14 but first sterling probably would
be so if you you look at it but it's a
gentle slope upwards but so the real
world is only expanding you know it come
back to the cheap money argument the the
the stop by well it obviously is
different the money question is do you
in your strategy for 2015 adjust to Kate
Moore's world do you have a timidness
because of janet yellen mario draghi and
mr. pal we've got the strange balance of
my makeup you know us tightening b.r.j
yet more liquidity europe more liquidity
the honest answer you question is we
will continue to be cautious as we go
into 2015 reflecting our client activity
which is to be cautious not to be
expansive came more your clients at
JPMorgan Chase they're not they're not
consider not thinking about median
incomes because they're not dealing with
median incomes but part of the new
mediocre is this stagnating income over
time that just isn't going anywhere as
the fact going down is that a problem
for the stock market going forward will
that eventually catch up with us this
lack of consumption actually I think the
lack of consumption is more of an issue
for GDP data than it is for corporate
earnings if you look at what drives
corporate earnings it's much more
business investment and we need to see
company management teams feel like they
have more clarity and like they have a
greater visibility into the future
before they continue to invest we
mention this a little bit when we were
talking about deal flow and whether or
not we were going to see companies
reinvest in themselves or look to
acquire spin-off assets they thought
were undervalued in the market you know
what we really want to see as I was
saying before is the capex we want to
see companies invest back in themselves
and really say we have this confidence
in the future that in and of itself will
be a propeller for earnings and we
expect them to be the next leg for
hiring what are your clients saying in
terms of policy differential how do they
want to be positioned going into next
year look it's a little bit confusing
for everyone but everyone feels
confident that the US recovery is on
track in fact we're now saying we're not
in recovery but in fact an expansionary
phase of the US economic cycle that's
not quite the case for Europe in Japan
we're more neutral on European equities
we have some opportunistic positions in
Japanese equities but you asked because
of its
fanchon is our highest conviction call